L'actualité dans le domaine du design et chez IDEO
a été très excitante durant l'année écoulée,
et je suis heureux d'avoir la possibilité de la partager avec vous.
Je n'étais pas présent au premier TED en 1984
mais j'y ai assisté souvent depuis.
J'ai pensé qu'il serait intéressant de se remémorer cette époque
lorsque Richard a lancé tout cela. Merci pour tout, Richard,
venir ici a été très enrichissant pour moi, un moment vraiment agréable.
Et en y repensant, je me disais que
ceux de la Silicon Valley étaient vraiment centrés sur les produits ou les objets
et en particulier les objets technologiques.
C'était particulièrement excitant en ces temps-là, et certains parmi vous
présents dans le public étaient mes clients.
Nous sommes venus avec un prototype dissimulé sous une cape noire,
nous l'avions posé sur la table de conférence,
et en enlevant la cape, tout le monde s'était écrié "ouh" et "ah".
Ce fut un moment vraiment super.
Nous continuerons de nous concentrer sur les produits, comme nous l'avons toujours fait.
Si vous étiez présents l'année dernière,
je vous ai probablement traîné au rez-de-chaussée pour vous montrer mon nouveau EyeModule n°2,
une caméra montée sur un Palm.
J'ai pris beaucoup de photos l'année dernière,
peu de gens savaient sur quoi je travaillais, mais j'ai pris un tas de photos.
Cette année -- on peut peut-être montrer les diapos --
cette année, nous avons ce Tréo, sur lequel on a beaucoup travaillé
pour aider Handspring à le concevoir.
Ainsi, bien que nous l'ayons créé il y a quelques années --
il s'est répandu partout seulement l'année dernière --
voici un défibrillateur HeartStream qui sauve des vies.
Peut-être les avez-vous vus dans des aéroports? Ils ont l'air d'être partout désormais.
Beaucoup ont été sauvés grâce à eux.
Nous sommes sur le point d'annoncer le Zinio Reader
qui, je le pense, va rendre les magazines encore plus agréables à lire.
Nous allons réellement continuer à nous concentrer sur les produits.
Mais certaines choses ont changé en 18 ans, depuis que Richard a créé TED,
des gens comme nous --
je sais que dans d'autres lieux d'autres personnes ont commencé depuis longtemps,
mais pour nous, nous avons juste commencé
à grimper un peu sur la pyramide de Maslow --
nous sommes désormais de plus en plus focalisés sur le design centré sur l'humain.
Le centrage sur l'humain est une approche du design.
Cela implique vraiment d'intégrer le comportement et la personnalité dans les produits.
Je pense qu'on commence à voir ça,
ce qui rend nos métiers encore plus passionnants.
De manière assez intéressante, nous avions l'habitude de créer des modèles 3D --
vous en avez vu certains aujourd'hui -- et un rendu en 3D.
Ensuite nous les montrions afin de communiquer nos idées.
Mais des sociétés comme la nôtre ont dû aller au point où
nous créons les objets que nous concevons et les animons
pour montrer comment ils seront utilisés.
Pour parvenir à cela, nous avons créé
des groupes de production vidéo en interne,
afin de créer ces sortes de prototypes
qui montrent ce que signifie pour nous la relation homme-machine.
C'est une bien meilleure manière de les voir.
C'est comme les architectes qui montrent les gens dans leurs maisons,
au lieu de les présenter vides.
Ainsi j'ai pensé que je pourrais vous montrer quelques-unes de ces vidéos
afin que vous perceviez cette nouvelle définition étendue
de création de produits, de services et d'environnements.
J'en ai quelques-unes avec moi -- elles ne durent pas plus d'une minute,
une minute trente --
mais j'ai pensé que vous pourriez être intéressés de voir certains
de nos travaux de l'an passé, et comment cela se traduit en vidéo.
Donc, Prada à New York : Rem Koolhaas et OMA nous ont demandé
d'aider à concevoir la technologie
qui est dans leur magasin de New York.
Il voulait une nouvelle sorte de magasin -- quelque chose de nouveau --
un magasin qui aurait un rôle culturel autant que commercial.
Cela signifiait de concevoir en fait notre propre technologie
au lieu de simplement acheter des trucs tout faits et les mettre en place.
Il y a donc beaucoup de choses. Tout a une étiquette RFID:
l'utilisateur, les cartes,
voici les appareils placés partout dans la boutique.
Vous en prenez un, et quand vous voyez quelque chose qui vous intéresse,
le personnel peut les scanner
et ces objets peuvent être affichés sur n'importe quel écran du magasin.
Vous pouvez choisir la couleur, la taille, son look dans la rue, etc.
Et ainsi l'objet -- le produit qui vous intéresse --
peut être scanné. Apporté dans la cabine d'essayage,
où se trouve des scanners
qui nous permettent de connaître exactement les vêtements que vous avez.
Nous pouvons les afficher sur un écran tactile
et vous pouvez vous amuser avec, obtenir plus d'information
sur le vêtement qui vous intéresse pendant que vous l'essayez.
Cette technologie a souvent été utilisée, mais j'aime particulièrement cet usage
d'écran à cristaux liquides dans la cabine.
La dernière fois que je suis allé voir cette boutique,
il y avait un énorme buzz : des gens se tenaient à l'extérieur et se demandaient,
"Vais-je réellement voir les gens se changer ici?"
Mais si vous appuyez sur le bouton, bien évidemment, le mur redevient opaque.
Vous pouvez avoir l'avis, ou pas, sur ce tout ce que vous essayez.
L'un de mes éléments préférés de la technologie
est le miroir magique, devant lequel vous vous habillez.
Le miroir a un grand afficheur, vous tournez sur vous-même --
mais il y a un délai de trois secondes.
Vous pouvez ainsi voir votre look de tous les côtés, pendant que vous regardez.
(Applaudissements)
Il y a environ un an et demi on nous a demandé de concevoir
une installation pour un musée --
voici une nouvelle aile du Science Museum à Londres,
concernant d'abord les questions numériques et biomédicales.
Un groupe d'Itch, qui fait partie d'IDEO,
a conçu ce mur interactif qui fait 4 étages de haut.
Je ne sais pas si l'un d'entre vous l'a vu --
c'est plutôt spectaculaire une fois dans la pièce.
Bref, c'est basé sur le réseau du métro londonien.
Vous pouvez voir que
le but est d'incorporer les retours
que nous font les gens qui ont visité le musée,
et les afficher sur le mur à la vue de tous. Juste pour que tous les voient.
Vous entrez votre texte. Ensuite, comme dans le métro de Londres,
les petits trains circulent avec ce que vous avez écrit.
Et quand vous arrivez à une station, cela s'élargit pour pouvoir être lu.
Quand vous quittez le cinéma IMAX du 4e étage --
ce sont surtout des ados qui en sortent --
il y a un large espace ouvert avec ces tables,
qui proposent des jeux interactifs plutôt amusants,
également conçus par Durrel [Bishop] et Andrew [Hirniak] d'Itch.
Les thèmes incluent ceux qui concernent le musée :
la fertilité masculine, le choix du sexe de votre enfant
ou à quoi une voiture sans chauffeur pourrait ressembler.
Il y a beaucoup de place, les gens peuvent donc venir
et comprendre ce dont il s'agit avant de s'y essayer.
Également, ce n'est pas dans la vidéo, mais elles sont très belles.
Elles vont vers le haut du mur et quand elles l'atteignent,
après avoir rebondi, elles se dispersent en milles morceaux
et partent dans l'atmosphère.
La vidéo suivante n'a pas été produite par nous.
Elle provient de CBS Sunday Morning -- diffusée il y a environ 2 semaines.
Scott Adams est venu nous rencontrer
et nous a demandé si nous ne pouvions pas l'aider à concevoir
le cubicle ultime pour Dilbert,
ce qui nous a semblé amusant, on n'a donc pas pu refuser.
Il a toujours été intéressé par la technologie dans le futur.
(Vidéo : Scoot Adams : J'ai compris à un certain moment que je pourrais
être l'expert mondial dans ce qui ne va pas avec les cubicles.
On a donc pensé, eh bien, est-ce que cela ne serait pas amusant de travailler
avec certains des types les plus calés en design dans le monde
et essayer d'imaginer comment rendre le cubicle meilleur?
Narrateur : Bien qu'ils travaillent dans un large bureau ouvert
placé de manière spectaculaire sous le pont Oakland Bay à San Francisco,
l'équipe a construit ses propres cubicles
pour vivre pleinement les problèmes.
Femme : Miroir sans tain. Je peux regarder dehors, vous vous voyez.
Narrateur : Ils ont pris des photos.
Femme : On se sent si coincé, quand quelqu'un se penche par-dessus
et on est en quelque sorte captif pendant un instant.
SA : Pour l'instant, c'est le chaos, mais beaucoup de personnes font des choses, c'est bien.
On verra bien ce qui en arrivera.
Narrateur : Le premier groupe construit un cubicle dont les murs sont des écrans
pour l'ordinateur et les photos de famille.
Dans le scénario du 2e groupe, les murs sont vivants
et donnent en fait l'accolade à Dilbert.
(Rires)
Au-delà de l'humour est l'idée de rendre le cubicle plus humain.
David Kelley: Voici enfin le final, complet avec un éclairage orange
qui suit le soleil -- qui suit sa course -- dans le ciel.
Et donc vous le ressentez dans votre cubicle.
Enfin, voici mon invention favorite, une fleur dans un vase
qui dépérit de déception quand vous partez,
quand vous revenez, elle se redresse pour vous accueillir, elle est heureuse de vous voir.
(SA: Les rangements sont construits directement dans le mur.)
DK : Il y a quelques touches personnelles, comme un aquarium dans le mur,
ou une sorte de punching ball pour relâcher la tension.
(SA: Adaptable au chef de votre choix.)
DK: Et bien sûr, un hamac pour la sieste de l'après-midi
qui s'attache de part et d'autre du cubicle.
(SA: La vie serait douce dans un cubicle comme celui-ci.)
DK: Projet suivant : on nous a demandé de concevoir un pavillon pour mettre en avant
le recyclage de l'eau dans le Millenium Dome de Londres.
Le dôme nécessite une quantité d'eau incroyable pour le laver,
qui devient des eaux usées.
Ce bâtiment célèbre donc en fait l'eau
qui vient de la station d'épuration et va dans la roselière
afin d'être filtré pour la dernière fois.
Le but du design du pavillon était d'être calme et tranquille.
Par contraste avec l'intérieur du dôme, où tout
est frénétique et où tout le monde
apprend plein de choses, traîne, ou quoi que ce soit d'autre.
Mais c'était conçu pour être plutôt calme.
Ainsi, vous pourriez vous promener, obtenir de l'information,
d'une manière directe, sur le processus de recyclage,
sur ce qui est fait, et sur comment on allait réutiliser l'eau
une fois sorti de la station.
Comme vous le voyez,
les panneaux peuvent tourner. Vous pouvez donc obtenir de l'information
sur le recto, mais comme ils tournent, vous voyez la station
réelle derrière, avec toutes ses machines qui traitent effectivement l'eau.
Vous voyez : voici la station.
Ce sont des vidéos à petit budget, des sortes de prototypes rapides.
Ce soir, nous vous annonçons un nouveau produit
qui va être montré pour la première fois en public.
Il s'appelle Spyfish, de la société H2Eye
qui a été fondée par Nigel Jagger à Londres.
Cette société essaye de simuler -- beaucoup de gens ont un bateau,
ou aiment être en bateau, mais très peu de gens
ont réellement la possibilité ou la volonté d'aller sous l'eau
de voir ce qui s'y passe,
et d'apprécier ce que les plongeurs apprécient.
Ce produit a deux caméras.
Vous le mettez sous l'eau à côté de votre bateau
et en gros, vous plongez sans être mouillé.
Voici l'objet. Pour nous, c'était deux projets. Un, concevoir l'interface
de manière à ce qu'elle ne soit pas perceptible.
Il fallait que vous ayez l'impression immersive d'être sous l'eau --
ou la sensation d'y être -- rien qu'en le voyant.
Deux, concevoir l'objet lui-même
et s'assurer qu'il serait vendable et pas seulement un outil de recherche.
Nous avons donc passé beaucoup de temps -- ceci a pris environ
sept à huit ans, ce projet --
et nous sommes désormais prêts à le construire.
(Narrateur : Le Spyfish est une caméra subaquatique révolutionnaire.
Elle peut descendre à 150 mètres, où la lumière du soleil ne pénètre pas,
elle est équipée de puissantes lampes.
Elle devint vos yeux et vos oreilles quand vous vous aventurez dans les profondeurs.
Alimenté par une batterie, le Spyfish envoie en direct un flux vidéo via un mince câble.)
DK: Ce câble mince est une avancée technologique considérable
qui permet à l'ensemble d'avoir cette taille.
(Narrateur: Cette boite centrale connecte l'ensemble du système.
Manœuvrer le Spyfish est très simple grâce à la télécommande sans fil.
Vous regardez la vidéo avec des graphiques superposés
qui indiquent la profondeur et la direction.
La fluidité de l'image et les bruits d'ambiance se mélangent
pour vous perdre complètement sous l'eau.)
(Applaudissements)
DK: La dernière chose dont je vais parler est ApproTEC,
un projet qui m'excite beaucoup.
ApproTEC est une société fondée par le Dr Martin Fisher,
un bon ami à moi. Il a eu un doctorat à Stanford.
Grâce à une bourse Fulbright, il s'est retrouvé au Kenya,
il a eu une inspiration très intéressante : il s'est dit :
"Il doit y avoir des entrepreneurs au Kenya,
il doit y en avoir partout."
Il a remarqué que, pour les mariages et les enterrements,
les gens arrivaient à trouver l'argent pour tout organiser.
Il a donc décidé de commencé à fabriquer des produits au Kenya
avec des ouvriers kényans -- conçus par des gens comme nous, mais faits là-bas.
A ce jour -- il n'y est que depuis quelques années --
il a lancé 19000 entreprises.
Il a créé 30000 nouveaux emplois.
La seule vente des produits -- tout ceci est à but non lucratif --
la vente de ces produits représente maintenant 0,6% du PIB du Kenya.
Juste une personne derrière ça. C'est plutôt impressionnant.
Nous sommes donc en train de les aider à concevoir
des pompes manuelles pas chères mais profondes
afin de permettre aux gens qui ont un lopin de terre
de faire pousser leurs récoltes à la saison sèche.
Voilà ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui : ils font pousser à la saison des pluies
mais pas à la saison sèche.
En faisant cela, la femme que vous avez vue dans le premier film --
une maîtresse d'école -- a toujours voulu envoyer ses enfants à l'Université
et elle va y parvenir grâce à ces pompes.
Grâce aux presses à semences ou à foin, aux pompes,
aux choses simples que nous concevons --
mes étudiants à Stanford font ceci comme projets de cours
et IDEO permet à ses employés de faire cela sur leur temps de travail --
c'est vraiment étonnant de voir ce succès, celui de Martin.
Nous avons aussi pensé à l'expérience de Richard,
et donc --
(Rires)
nous avons créé ce chapeau, car je savais que je serais le dernier aujourd'hui
et j'avais besoin de le traiter. Il me reste encore une chose à dire.
(Rires)
Arrivez-vous à lire ?
Eh bien, c'est toujours amusant quand il vient et hésite.
On ne veut pas être impoli avec lui, ni se sentir coupable,
j'ai donc pensé que cela suffirait, d'où je suis assis.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Nous avons vu un tas de choses intéressantes en train d'être créées dans cette session,
par tous ces présentateurs.
De ma propre expérience, du produit à ApproTEC,
c'est vraiment excitant que nous ayons une approche du design plus centrée sur l'humain,
que nous incluions les comportements et les personnalités dans les objets.
Je trouve cela super.
On a beaucoup plus confiance dans les designers et ils sont mieux intégrés
dans la stratégie commerciale des entreprises,
et je dois dire, pour une fois, que je me sens véritablement chanceux de voir
les progrès que le design à fait depuis le premier TED. Merci beaucoup.